now for the uplifted eight the stories
that bring you some joy vlad i want some
new smile lines all right you're gonna
get some new smile lines today you're
gonna be smiling about this all day long
i promise we are bringing you a very
very very big celebration watch this
[Applause]
so that is five-year-old henry furman he
is ringing the bell after winning a two
and a half year battle with leukemia
it's a tradition for cancer patients to
ring a bell to mark the end of their
treatment get this guys henry went
through 45 rounds of chemotherapy at
children's hospital in tennessee he
celebrated with his parents his nurses
and the doctors who helped him along the
way and henry shared a message for other
kids battling cancer
if i can do it you can do it
pretty simple yeah i can do it you can
do it henry plans to spend his summer
hiking swimming and bowling
congratulations henry brave guys why is
your smile lines for sure right you're
going to be smiling all day long and he
rang that bell with gusto too
i like that that is awesome oh man that
was my heart thank you brian we
appreciate you